Hi, Karen, how are you?
I'm good, how are you?
Good, thanks for asking.
Be Ashish.
Alex had mentioned that, was it Ahmed is in the hospital?
So he, Aman, had some surgery, I think, last week. I think surgery related to some back. And surgery went good, but he is in that recovery period at home right now. Almost done. We were supposed, he was supposed to come back by.
This week, but hopefully he will join by next.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I wasn't sure if we were still having the meeting.
No, Ashish is backing up him from last two weeks since he's out. So he's taking care, he's leading that part.
Okay.
Hey, Karen, Eric.
Hi, Ashish.
Hello!
How are you?
All good.
Gary, how are you doing?
Sure, sure.
Anyone else shining, Karen?
Is it a lag?
I thought Aleks was joining.
I love you.
Let me just check, hold on.
Sure.
Oh, there he is.
Good afternoon, Aleks.
Aleks.
You are a new Ted Aleks.
Hello.
I know, Karen, next time I'm I know that you Karen likes to.
Hey.
the meetings, Karen, just ping me like a 2:02, because I just, I know, I know where I'm, but yeah, no, that's fine. I was like, oh, shoot, I gotta get on before Karen sends me a reminder. He sent me a reminder at 2.
Yeah.
Alright.
Fancy.
Give me 60 seconds of lateness.
Tardiness.
Keith.
Rita.
Hello, Ashish, how are you?
Kip.
Yes, I'm doing great, Alex. Before we start off, let me just give you a quick intro about myself. So my name is Ashish, working with IT by Design as a senior technical team lead. So as Aman is out of office because of his medical situation, so I'm taking care of ABMIT in his absence.
So in terms of engineers management, their availability, everything is being taken care of by me in its absence.
Alright, good.
Yep.
Okay.
Sounds good.
I think I might have to reboot my computer because at some point I'm still having audio issues. Karen, how about you? Are you having any audio issues?
No, I seem to be fine.
Okay.
I'll survive because I hope this will be a quick meeting.
I appreciate the introduction.
Hello, Rick. And don't ask me to provide KPI scorecards today. I will have to punch all through the wall if you ask me that question. So let's just let's just continue to table that conversation.
Yeah.
We do have the QBR coming up in two weeks, and you know, and then we'll hopefully be...
Yep.
you know, talking more about that type of stuff as well as...
Because right now, essentially...
Our goal as a company is to get everybody working more in their areas that I want them to be subject matter experts in.
doing proactive work.
But everything is working out pretty good.
And we had a pretty good call today.
Sort of trying to get aligned, understanding that we've added.
Because we've added two more people.
Yeah, we've had some challenges with...
tickets actually being less efficiently dealt with, with too many people sort of just staring at the same ticket, you know. And I really focused on helping people understand that they have to use ConnectWise correctly in terms of assignment and I have a trust level and understand how to use that system. I even said during the call that
Mhm.
You can go through 40 hours of training and hear the same stuff. And I'm saying like you can go through a 40 hours of ConnectWise training. And that's exactly the way that you would be trained to handle a ticket. And you guys are all professionals and you all should know how to do that. Including the customer facing notes.
Yeah.
internal notes, scheduling, utilizing other resources, assigning other resources. So we talked about that stuff.
because there tends to be a little bit of a...
And that's okay. You know, we've had some, you know, it's happened before, but this time I think we're going to handle it a lot better. But that is if you, you know, have.
A bit of disorder, you know, you can have...
you hire more people and you have five people now staring at 2 tickets instead of two people staring at each one ticket or something, you know. You know, so, you know, so, yeah, go ahead.
So, so I'm maybe...
Maybe I missed on because I was not joining a couple of calls earlier, but do we have any dispatch team, service team on your side who is assigning these tickets or engineers picking tickets by themselves?
Absolutely. No, no, no, they, they, no, no, no, we don't have a service team. You know, if you go historically, we had, we had hired, at one point, we had a service coordinator. Can you hear me?
Thomas.
Yep, yep.
Okay, we had a Tom, the service coordinator on your side. It was pretty pointless. It was actually counterproductive. So we eliminated that position. And there's also no need for that position.
Yes, we can.
Take an assignment. If 10 minutes goes by and nobody has taken the ticket on their respective, they all come in through one support board. We have boards, they break out to separate boards, but if somebody emails us, they come in through the support board, we have the board is monitored by Shivani.
Vincent and Summer in that order. So Shivani, if she's not available, then Vincent is monitoring that board. If Shivani, if nobody picks up a ticket in 10 minutes, it's assigned automatically to Shivani to triage.
And either assign or address the issue. Everybody is trained on all of this. We have, we have a...
I got it.
you know, board workflow spreadsheets I can share on the call if you want.
See, could you share this for just for fun?
Sharing this whole screen now, if I were to pull up.
Say.
I have shared with them on, you know, all of our meetings. We have all these internal meetings and these spreadsheets today, spreadsheet and so on, PowerPoint presentations, I should say, you know, these are.
You know, this is back in.
This was back in April when we started this approach every week.
Every week we talk about...
I also don't, I also am specifically.
trying not to focus on too much conversation on, like, I don't want to be repetitive. I don't want to do lectures, you know. So Karen, you may have noticed that during the call today. I was trying not to get into.
I specifically said I don't want to lecture you guys again on the same things over and over, right?
So, that's that, you know, these are all the slide decks that we go through every week. Okay. Now, what to do, et cetera, et cetera, how we walk through the tickets, but then who's joining the team and so on. But I'll show you, I'm just going to pop all these up, sharpening the craft.
We continue to review.
How to escalate things, what to do on tickets, how to handle your calendar. Okay, like it's repetitive. It's very repetitive. You know, what's the L1 ticket, L2, L3 ticket?
Go.
is doing what on a boards. Like these are all very, very clearly discussed, okay?
Um...
And you know, so, you know, these are things you don't witness.
Okay, again, this is now.
May.
Talking about other things that came up that week, so...
This looks good.
Okay, so there's like, you know, we just keep doing this over and over. Okay, and I obviously can't go through every presentation with you, but I'm showing you that there is tons of communication, right, that goes through.
This is, I am a bottleneck, right? So this was actually a point out, call out beginning of May, middle May, right? You know, velocity dies if you got to work with me, right? What do we do to prevent that? Okay.
So these are training decks. These are decks that are available to the staff all the time to review. All the calls are recorded with Fireflies, AI.
All the decks are shared via the meeting, Teams meeting. And they can use Fireflies, which is everybody's license for us. They can query all of our previous meetings.
So we even talked about fireflies.
This was.
Yep.
On the 20th.
Okay, uh, they...
Or, yeah, tiers of these are what we call what I started to break down level.
what our levels are. Yeah.
So Alex, a quick question that's around. So you have these attacks prepared for ConnectWise, Management, and how to use it and other avenues there. But I would like to know and understand if we have any mechanism to capture
Yeah.
how happy your customers are both getting this.
Yeah, yeah, we have CSAT scores. We have, and I know, and Karen, you can speak to this. We know how happy our customers are. And when they're unhappy, I am very quick to
Usually understand. We had, well, we had a customer just cancel the contract last week. I'm not going to put that on IT by Design at all, but I know what makes customers happy and unhappy. Let's take one example this morning, and we talked about it during the meeting.
on a mesh, because CSAT reviews, those are, you know, when customers often don't want to fill out a survey if it's negative, like they'll just, they'll just ignore it, right? So you don't never, you don't get to find out when a customer's unhappy all the time, right? It's very hard sometimes to find that out through a survey.
Sometimes we do get it back. We got one last week that was a negative survey response. And I'll show you.
right in our Teams chat, everybody, when I set them up, then I also tell them to make sure that they have these two groups. These are our CSAT scores coming back. Okay. And I actually told every time a Support 1 and Support 2 level ticket is completed, a customer gets a customer satisfaction survey.
Mhm.
20 minutes after that ticket is completed. That's A workflow of ConnectWise. Now.
Reid.
They can either say they are happy.
indifferent or unhappy. Okay, so it's got three options.
Kip.
And that goes out again to those two boards. We don't include those on other boards for on purpose. Like there's other boards that don't have CSAT scores that go out.
And, but we love seeing the raving fans and customers are very happy. We love seeing it, and I always notice it immediately.
And then we have like this this last week. And these are the ones that break the break the business is when.
You can have, you can have.
You can have 100 great reviews, but you can have one bad one, and that will be...
do a lot of damage from that customer, right? Or you might have, you might have nine really good reviews and you have one really bad one. That really stings for that customer. I'm not even talking about us, but that customer, you know, that customer, if they are.
Yup.
You know, that upset, right?
That can be a very big problem. Here they say, you know, we see like Stephanie here, right? I knew that she was upset. That's why I asked somebody else to look at the ticket. Before she filled out the survey, I knew that she was going to be angry. You can't have a tech log in to a machine and take over that machine for two hours.
We have to win every time.
okay? Without communication, coordination, thinking, you know what I mean? Like you can't just log into the machine and troubleshoot a printing problem for two hours and expect the customer to be happy and then not even have it fixed and then reach out three, four, five more times that afternoon. And then, you know what I mean? Like it's just going to be a horrible experience. I think anybody should know this is common sense.
So the technicians need to be self-aware. They need to be good at customer service, right?
That is something I expect, right? Those are table stakes, right? So I expect Shivani and even Animesh, right? Animesh is a less experienced MSP, but I expect him to be self-aware. You can't be in the service provider business if you don't know how to provide service. Understand?
Absolutely. Yep.
service provider business, it's not up to me to teach you how to be good at that. You need to be good at that. It's like if you get hired as a waiter in a restaurant and you're a bad waiter, then you shouldn't be a waiter. Yeah? Okay? It's simple.
Yeah.
I agree.
It's that simple. You know what I mean? So we're talking about basic concepts. So conceptually, you need to have good bedside manner. You need to know how to fix problems fast. You need to get the person fixed to be on their good side, right? All these things, whether you get a survey back or not, I know these things, right?
Yeah.
I know, like for example, I know Summer, I can tell by the way Summer is working, that he's hitting all the marks. Summer.
is satisfying the technical requirements, he's satisfying the customer requirements, he's documenting all the work in the tickets. There's some issues, he still has some issues regarding, you know, passing tickets back and forth, scheduling. He's got some issues with that that he needs to work on, right? You know, some of the time management, some of the, you know,
Some of that stuff, and being able to run ConnectWise absolutely correctly, but...
Kip.
He's doing an exceptional job. If I give him something, I know he's going to dig deep, he's going to solve it, he's going to make sure the customer disruptions are minimal, right? These are things that matter, you know, and these are things that he's doing. So I'm very happy with what Summer's doing there, because he can dig deep and do this. And he doesn't get lost in the weeds that way. So
Now my concern with the less experienced, let's say L3 or L2 is that they might, for example, take a user's computer for two to three hours without even thinking about the user, because the user is going to be sitting there, they're like, holy crap, I'm trying to get work done today. Could you imagine somebody, if you said my computer's running slow and somebody just
Took over your computer, so let me take a look at it, and it didn't say anything to you for two hours?
Yeah.
Yeah, could you imagine that?
There's extremely bad, bad customer experience.
Right, right. And then, and then, and then after two hours, they tell you, we're not sure if we fixed it or, you know, again, just not even doesn't even matter at that point. You need to be, you need to have a plan, a resolution plan, a plan to resolution, right? So like I can touch almost every single ticket I can touch in 5 minutes and actually come up with a plan to resolution.
Yes.
right? We have a plan to resolution. That's important to have very, very early, you know, and then that plan can change, right? After you work for 15 minutes, maybe you've discovered something else or whatever, but you have to have a plan to resolution. You can't just go blindly about things, right?
Um...
So anyway, yes, we do have CSAT scores and they come in via crew who we have crew who we can look at those scores. Everybody gets points. I haven't decided how to give everybody what to give them with points, but they get points. You know, again, this is the internal meetings. I'm going to go ahead.
You know, this is a good one, right? Status. A ticket is the work. I continue to remind everybody, if it's not in the ticket, it didn't happen. If you didn't, you know, I look at a ticket 2 hours later and there's not a ticket. The customer didn't get a ticket update. There is no ticket update or your calendar is behind. You know, there's no time entries. You know, all these things.
These are all just normal things. They can't, it shouldn't dominate the conversation, right? I should be thinking at a different level, a higher level or better level. We talk about things like training, implementation projects and stuff like that. And we're getting there and that's fine. You know, I'm actually not unhappy.
Overall, you know, I've been frustrated in the past couple of weeks, I think. But that's also on my on me. You know, I explained that during the call today. Because it's on me.
to further make it very clear what everyone's given role and responsibilities are, right?
You know, we talked about the new shifts in the board and how everybody functions. Now, Aman followed up on this. I created this deck. I don't know why he recreated the same exact deck.
in Claude, but this was actually, you know, you could just, again, I shared all these with Aman, but not you, with you as Ashish. You know, he was able to see these just before he got, had to go out.
you know, but these are shift coverage and so on.
I do want to show you something else real quick.
Johal.
Which I continue to remind, you know, people, people say, you know, they get.
They get, you know, trying to make some clarity around like boards, service boards, who's responsible with the service boards. We have three service boards, we have a monitoring board.
We have a backup board, we have informational alerts, security alerts, implementation board, and who is responsible for each of those.
This is just a reference, okay? I mean, everybody knows without having to necessarily go onto the sheet, but I'll bring the sheet back up if I have to. I'll say, okay, why is, you know, support falling through while...
Shivani's at lunch, right? So we'll say, okay, well, like yesterday I asked somebody, I said, what happened to this ticket? This somebody says, oh, you know, Shivani's at lunch. I'm like, wait a minute, that shouldn't matter.
What do you mean? We're not servicing a customer because Shivani is at lunch? Right? That's not a good answer, right? Do we do agree? I don't hire five people at IT by design so that I have one person, you know, out and nothing works, right?
Secondary means Vincente. So that's what we follow same on our side. We have primary, secondary, and even a backup resource that if both are on leave, so we'll be managing that boat, right? So that's correct.
Right, so.
Yeah, so this is not very hard, right? Because look, it says it right here, right?
Yep.
Okay, so, and I asked them to train on these. I asked, I share these. Everybody has access to these documents so they can see exactly what our plan is, right?
Alerts team on a mesh, number one. You got to process the alerts. Summer, secondary and escalations. Infrastructures and service teams, summers, number one. We have no secondary. I'm escalations. There is nobody secondary for IAS.
Vincent, security team, Vincent, secondary, Shabani, escalations, Alex, BCDR. Actually, this has to be updated because this is Seth now, right? So somebody could easily, somebody could always easily say that, you know, call me out on this. And I encourage it.
Yep, yep, I was about to say it.
If somebody says, "Ohh, well, I gotta go out of here and fix this."
implementations team, Karen, Vincent, and so on. So informational alerts. So the boards look like this. So you can see.
You know, we have a backup and recovery board. Steph owns this board. Okay.
These are the tickets he owns now.
There should probably be a lot more tickets here, to be honest, but...
But...
You know, one of the things was that Aman wanted access to our ConnectWise. We created a...
Um...
Gosh, I don't even know if I gave him a login, but my intent was to give him a virtual desktop to log into because he wants API access #1 and he wants a login potentially user login, neither of which we have direct.
We don't, we can't give that directly this way.
We still have to reconcile this question.
But all the tickets come in on IT Support 1. Okay, so these are the tickets that come in and Shivani is looking at. I've seen Shivani make, oh, I know why, because my name is there. So I have a filter on my name. Okay, so we go to backup. You'll now see more tickets.
Ohh.
Okay, there's a few more tickets in here. This is Seth's board. Yeah? We go to Support One. This is Shivani's board. All the tickets come in, they come in through Support One if it's like a customer e-mail. Monitor tickets come in through the monitor board, all of our, you know, servers, down situations, things like that come in through the monitor board.
Yep.
Um...
Kip.
and Automation Summer need to be monitoring that board and they're responsible for that board.
Security alerts and remediations, if Vincent is responsible for this board.
Um...
You know, security at you guys, GRC is like a sort of a higher level board. There's, it's on me.
tools and platform, APM stack. So actually, what's interesting about where I want Summer's, Summer and Vincent are almost like a, I hope long term for them to be a hybrid team for me. Essentially, my goal is so that anything that needs to be done doesn't require my.
like, for example, administrative rights internally to ConnectWise, all of our stack tools, etc. They can create logins, they can, they can, they can, you know, troubleshoot an issue so they don't call me and say, oh, I'm having trouble with cyber QP. You know, I don't need to be on the phone for that. We just need somebody that is skilled enough at that point.
platform that has the admin rights to be able to log in and make changes and adjustments to that platform. And CyberQP, for example, is something that's in Vincent's wheelhouse.
Kip.
Okay. Vincent's Wheelhouse is also the Microsoft Cloud environments. You know, we've been really focused on giving you the Microsoft Cloud environments. We have a lot of work to do there. Our security stack is Vincent's world.
Um...
That's our plan.
Or rather, our additional plan is Summer's Summer's World is infrastructure as a service, desktop as a service, networking, VMware is quite versatile in his skill set. You know, he can handle complex issues very, very well, especially across network and infrastructure.
You know, Summer's very good at that. He's also very good at troubleshooting any random problem I want to give him. You know, he just, I give him anything and he doesn't need to ask questions as to, oh, where is that device? Who are the logins? Which PCs do the people use? He figures this all out, right?
Yeah.
You know, we had an issue with a printer or a copier or a customer, brand new customer. I didn't have any documentation. And even if I did, documentation is a funny thing because people want documentation, but then they don't use the documentation. So anyway, he's able to log in and very quickly figure it out, right?
That.
He can determine this because we have full access, right? So we have the admin rights to the network. We have admin rights. We have our RMM platform with all of our agents deployed, right? So there's our agents over here. So he can go right into this particular customer. And if he knows all the users, he can very quickly see the usernames here.
Right? Support the machines.
Yeah.
The.
log into our jump boxes, do network scans, you know.
I mean, all the data is here, right? Yeah, I mean, there's there's some of the data, and then we have, we have, of course, ConnectWise and Secret Service is our privileged access management system, you guys can see.
Yep.
So if you go into like one of our accounts, we have 4 levels. We have break glass accounts, land admin, knock admin, and user accounts. These are documented in our back end privilege access management system.
And then we utilize cyber QP.
for just in time accounts, admin privileges, things like that, if you guys are familiar with that.
you know, just in time accounts, password rotation and privilege elevation. Okay. We have so many tools, it's crazy, right? To summit can be overwhelming, but each tool is, you know, put these tools together and that's what gives you.
Just in time.
Exactly.
Okay.
Gives you what you need.
But yeah, look, I mean, I'm just rambling on about things. The question that Ashish had, I just decided to just keep talking. He had a seesaw question and the answer was yes.
All right, Aleks, I mean, you have been detailed about explaining everything. And it is good to know that you have so many tools to monitor each and everything and how you are lacking the team, especially Sameer. I know he is one of the technical guys in your team who is someone that you can be handy with.
any technology or any level of tickets that you need him to work on. And now we have in addition, Saf, who is a backup expert, and obviously he can help in backup technologies, which will obviously offload some of the work from your end as well as from Sameer side.
Yeah, look, I had two big areas that were very major areas that I haven't been able to hand off, which now the goal is to hand off to Summer and to Seth, right? Seth is supposed to be able to take care of our backup universe, right? And our universe, they are supposed to be expanding, growing, and improving.
You know, we use Veeam. He had certain tools he wanted to use, but we're probably not going to use them. Spanning, we're not going to necessarily use. But the point is that.
As a subject matter expert, as a backup expert, we're probably going to end up using three, 4, five different technologies and he should be able to handle all those technologies, all those platforms. And you know, we're building, our goal is for Seth to be responsible to build reports, right? He really did that before and he's going to be building the reports and...
backups, as well as our other platforms, because backup alone is not really technically a full-time job, right, for us right now. And we can utilize CEF to build reports across our cybersecurity platforms, other, you know, services and platforms, because our goal is to get those into a central location.
To share those with the customers.
Okay, alright, so...
Okay.
Um...
You know, I think Vincent's also been very, very good. We get good, great reviews with Vincent, and we're getting great reviews with Seth, or I'm sorry, Summer. So those two were getting really good reviews with customers. Honestly, with Shivani, we're not getting a lot, we're getting some real
Yep.
Mixed reviews with Shamani, unfortunately.
Um, people's people have been frustrated, right? Some.
Some people say they can't understand her, I think.
The truth is, I think Shivani has a couple of different like octaves of volume. Like she can speak very clearly, but sometimes she can be less like, you know, open, you know, on the call. So I think that that might be, you know, she just needs to speak up a little bit sometimes or something like that.
But because I think she speaks wonderfully. I don't have any issues, but but we are getting mixed reviews, unfortunately. Right. So we want to we want to try to figure that out because that it's about turnaround time. It's about that thing that I was talking about customer service, the frustration they feel in the first time.
hour or two hours, right? That we need to be very careful about, right? Because our goal is not to put, I as a company don't even want to put a level one, let alone a level 2 on a call with a customer, because there's no reason. You can have a customer feel amazing by solving a problem in 3 minutes.
right, by having a very skilled person address that issue. I believe Shivani can do that. She just needs to understand what are her limits and if she needs to escalate the ticket, but she also needs to make sure she's taking on the responsibilities of her role, you know?
Yep.
Having a deep, deep, deep enough understanding and being sharp, right? She needs to be sharp and accurate, right? So...
I think.
I think that that's my expectation.
at an entry-level position at APM, right?
And I think Shivani is just on that borderline, right? She's just on that border where, you know, she's...
having a tough time on some things and we get mixed customer reviews. And we don't want any, because again, one bad review outweighs 9 good reviews, usually, with a customer. That customer is going to, and if you've got the wrong person out there on the phone, you know, it could be a problem. You know, it could be like the CEO of the company.
Absolutely.
Um...
And I don't have VIP lists on purpose because everybody's a VIP that calls in. You don't know who's sitting next to the boss, who's who. You don't know really who's who. So everybody needs the same level of service.
That calls in.
Yep, yep.
That's correct. And Alex, when you mentioned that every customer is important, honestly, and we need to keep our customers happy. On similar lines, I would like to request you. This is not about KPI. This is not about the training plan for the nGenius. I'm coming from how happy you are.
So.
with the NGenius. So I would like to know that if we have received the CSAT surveys for our NGenius for the month of June.
Yeah, I'm afraid to answer them, right? Like, I don't, I don't want a, you know, I see those and it's the same thing.
You don't want to fill out a survey and say something negative and have it come off the wrong way, right? So it's hard for me to fill out a survey and say I'm unhappy, right?
Because I don't want to focus on that. I want to be constructive.
And it's tricky because I, you know, I know in the first couple of months when I had complaints, you guys would pull people into a meeting right now, and they would feel, you know, it's like, no, no, no, no, it's okay. It's like,
Yep.
Mm.
It's not going to happen this time. Trust me, Alex. As you said there, this is a constructive conversation and I really appreciate the way you look at things, have a holistic view of the things, being a business owner. Obviously, you have experience in this field.
for so long. So even if you have any areas of opportunity where you want engineers to work on, so rating does not matter at all, be it red, amber, or green. If it's green, obviously it's a plus point, but if it is amber, then what is the reason why you gave an amber to an engineer? This is all what we want to know.
And on the basis of the feedback that we get from you in those CSAT surveys, we will work with the engineers. It's not going to happen that you have a bunch of people jumping on the call next week and everyone would ask you, hey, Aleks, what's happening? What's going on? Why did you feel Amber? Why did you feel the right survey? No, it's not going to happen.
Yeah, look, I mean, the other part is like, if I fill out a survey and I say it's something, you know, amber or negative, then I have to think about what I'm going to be writing in there, right? And that can be challenging too. But yes, I see the surveys. I see some of them. I don't actually think I saw all of them.
I see Summer. I mean, I just see someone, two of them just now. I got Summer and Vincent just now.
I do not see when I think I've seen theirs a couple of times.
See if I get the other ones.
You will not get for Seth, but you will definitely get for Summer and Animesh Vincent and Shivani.
She wanted to get through.
Yeah, and okay, so I got, all right, I see Anna Mash, Vincent, Sameer. Yeah, I see everybody except Seth now.
Yep.
Um...
I don't know why I didn't get Seth, but I didn't get Seth, but...
Saf, you didn't get because he just started, because he just started, so he will get from next month.
The reason why you have not received ourselves?
Yeah, he just started.
I mean, and my concern right now is, unless, well, over the next month, we gotta execute and grow.
I.
I'm going to tell you right now, if I was told I would, I can give you an order who I would keep right now. It's very clear to me.
Rick.
Number one, summer. Number one is summer, period. If I was not able to keep anybody else, I would keep summer. Next, Vincent.
S.
Sameer.
Yeah, those are my top two.
Um...
And then after that.
I'd say Seth.
And then after that, Shivani, and then finally Animesh, right? You know, so that's where we're at right now. That's where that's where we're at as far as rating.
So I believe honestly I could if I like the whole reason we built a team is for growth, right?
Yes.
And I'm spending more money than I'm making, right, ultimately. I actually got to hire more people in the United States, et cetera. We have more hiring to do just to build out what I need to build out, right? And the whole reason to build it is to grow, right? If I didn't grow and I just said, oh, you know, I just want to go back to status quo, only keep the certain number of customers happy, and we're not trying to double our customer base.
Then I would just say, I would be able to, I would do that strictly with some summer events, right? Nobody else on the team. And then we'll, you know, we would just divide all the work and that's it, right? That's our goal is to grow. So what does this mean? That means we, the reason we have bandwidth to grow is so that everybody can meet together. First and foremost, there's more time.
Thank you.
People can train, people can work together, people can build standard operating procedures, people can understand the platforms deeply. That's important, right? I don't want people just to walk around and like look at the sky when they don't have a ticket, you know, or think, okay, what do I do? You need to train, you need to understand the platforms deeply.
You need to make sure all your tools are working, right? You know, build muscle memory, do a better job on the last ticket that you were working on, open another ticket for that customer. You know, I think ticket spawn is always a good sign that things are going well.
So if, you know, a customer reports an issue and we solve that problem and then they report two more issues, I don't consider that negative. I consider that positive because that means the customer believes in that person that they're working with. They believe in that person solving their problems. So that shows me that we're going in the right direction.
when we create more tickets. So sometimes people rate that as a negative in KPIs, right? That can be, you know, when I absolutely do not rate that as a negative. And when I see more tickets for the same user, I will actually look at that potentially as a positive, potentially, right? Because there's, oh, I have this problem, I have that problem, I have that problem.
You know, so they are building trust with those customers, so...
You know, so, but we're heading in the right direction. But I want the team to understand. And I also talked about patience today because I have been busy. We all just need to be patient. We're building a new team and you know, it's going to take time for us to get everything right. So, you know, I think we had a really positive call today.
As a team.
Yep, I feel the same. Thank you so much, Alex. I mean, I have never thought of a partner who is so much supportive, so much thoughtful about their team, their ingenious, to grow them technically, to grow with them and expand the business. I mean, I really appreciate
Kam.
So...
And I would like to join future calls as well. Even when Aman would, you know, rejoin post his recovery, I would still like to be a part of these calls just to get an insight how things are moving and where I can contribute to make things better.
That sounds exciting. I love it. I really appreciate it. All positivity. I just feel I just feel the positive energy and flow all the time. And Karen, you know, she's been able to be on the calls now for the past couple of months. And, you know, it's just been fantastic. So I appreciate it, Ashish. You have a great afternoon. Okay.
Thank you so much.
In the virtual.
Yeah. Great. Thank you so much, Alex. You too. Take care, Alex. Take care, Karen. You have a great day.
All right.
Thank you, you too. Bye.
What do you say?